here's an experiment type torture into
Google and what do you get beyond
snippets of Hillary's speeches you'll
see Gina Haspel the first woman to be
nominated to run the CIA a 33 year vet
more than qualified to run the place
with deep knowledge of our worst enemies
and how to handle them which means she
must be stopped on the other hand there
is controversy in her past she was
involved with the torture programs after
September 11th and then involved with
destroying videotapes of the matter also
that might be something that could be
problematic I oppose her because she
believes that waterboarding should be
something that we use and I think
America shouldn't be known for torture
Gina Haspel does not belong as a head of
the CIA
she belongs in front of a judge
answering to what she was doing running
a torture operation at a black site in
Thailand dig pretty deep for that one
all right fact is Gina made decisions
that few people ever have to make the
world she operated in and the villains
she faced she did had the luxury of just
talking about what to do she had to do
because the call she answered demanded
it so was it torture it wasn't back then
and just cuz you don't like a tactic
that doesn't make it torture of course
she could have discussed the merit of
such choices with pundits on TV rather
than doing her job she'd probably be
paid more but instead she took the risk
and responsibility so we didn't have to
she responded not just to the worst
attack on our country since Pearl Harbor
but to a world ending threat sure it's
easy to say but we're better than that
from a shiny newsroom but if you think
whatever she did was wrong what is your
alternative do you have anything beyond
don't do that have you ever even thought
this through all the way so here's a
question for hospitals critics imagine
being in a situation when your family's
in danger and a terrorist is withholding
key information that could save them
would you still consider enhanced
interrogation sadism with everything
that's considered mean be off the table
something tells me you'd rather leave
that question up to people like Gina
Haspel so Dana you know this story
be better than anybody they keep calling
this torture do they have a reason to
call it this stuff torture I don't it's
an opinion well I well it's their
personal opinion there has never been a
legal opinion right three attorneys
general have looked into this all of
them have declined to prosecute the
program was ended when it was no longer
needed and I I think about her in terms
of three three-decade career at the CIA
and all of a sudden now she's not
suitable to work at the CIA she has been
the deputy director of the CIA for the
last year and a half she has a great
reputation amongst not just Republicans
she's been serving since forty-ones
administration but also with the Obama
team right and what I would ask people
to think about is have we forgotten what
it was like on the morning after 9/11
yeah and what was happening she was
actually following orders okay she did
follow orders that were based on a
lawful program asked for by the
President of the United States and to
the subject that she destroyed evidence
there was no case that was ongoing when
those tapes were destroyed mm-hmm and
that might seem to some people like a
distinction without a difference but let
me just tell you if you're in the CIA do
you have reason to believe that the
congressional members of Congress who
are going to use this for decades now
we're almost eight tumor seventeen years
after the fact and they still want to
you know pick at the scab and not allow
a woman who has an amazing record of
public service to be able to serve it
that really chaps my hide if there are
clear reasons that she should not be
allowed to run this department that have
nothing to do with her work that has not
been questioned the program does not
exist in yeah that to me if she if she
if there's there's a substantial reason
fine let's have that discussion but this
one isn't it and grandstanding is so
just and it's gonna happen by the way I
think chapping your hide is worse than
waterboarding what I understand well you
could make it thing you could make that
case yes you could anything that I don't
like like honestly sleepless trip
pulling out fingernails like
yeah a lot of things yeah you know what
playing Greg's loud music that he plays
in the bunker that's what we play that
in a Thai prison they do what they do
they play a lot of Metallica and Slayer
but to me that's not torture that's a
beautiful music so one of the hardest
briefings I ever had to do at the White
House was I woke up in the morning got
the New York Times and there's a story
that the CIA has destroyed interrogation
tapes and I thought oh my gosh and I had
a talk to everybody that day the
president the vice president Mike Hayden
the former CIA director and Steve Hadley
the national security adviser and I
remember just having a private moment
with Steve Hadley before I went to the
briefing and he said Dana I just want to
explain something to you in those days
after 9/11 this country had to make some
really tough decisions and they were
tough but they were legal and they saved
lives and I went out and I had the best
briefing I'd ever had because I was
confident I think it's gonna be hard to
argue against her but they will argue
against her Kimberly if she was a
Democrat and it was under Hillary they
would say any opposition to her would be
sexist should we say that it's because
she's a woman do you think it's said
it's sexist I think it's ridiculous if
you want us to say it she's qualified
she deserves it okay one a lot of things
make you nuts
Cannavaro could've been he's gay and
Dana's pistachio Canadian torture is
anything sitting right here I don't like
beets very much no but you love super
beets my role I think that she's
unbelievably qualified and whether
male-female instead of based on her
record a career of distinction someone
who's able to make tough decisions who
is widely admired by her peers she
deserves this position they're gonna be
in a tough spot it works the other way
because she's a female because then they
will say okay why are you making these
attacks against her this could be
considered sexist she should get the job
and I do think they're gonna pull a
whole you know pork on her because you
have some of the background and tactics
and you know what because they're gonna
like the fanfare exactly
Hodder for certain shows the more they
talk about this the more president Trump
is gonna like her yeah exactly and it
will be it will be Jesse they'll be
Democrats galloping in on their moral
high horses they're also be Rand Paul
who's now gonna oppose pot Pompeo and
Haspel he's great yeah the moral high
horse to the Democrats I think who's the
Obama intelligence agencies that spied
on reporters that lied to the American
people in front of Congress that did a
lot of really disgusting things and they
didn't bat an eyelash then so get off
your high horse get off your soapbox
this woman's a patriot she was trying to
save lives after 9/11 I remember George
Bush on his last press conference said
exactly what you said you don't remember
what it was like here after 9/11 they
had to make a lot of tough decisions and
she made some tough decisions and the
head of her operation Jose Rodriguez
says that inherent interrogations save
lives and foil plots you know we'll also
said it Leon Panetta the Obama
intelligence chief and he said that
enhanced interrogation led to the
location of Osama bin Laden speaking of
Leon also Brennan clapper and Morell all
the top intelligence people under the
Obama administration all support this
woman so does Diane Feinstein which I
find is acting Stein excuse me and the
whole thing about her destroying the
tapes so she was told to destroy tapes
and she did Hillary destroyed tapes
because she wanted to and that was under
investigation you have to admire what he
just did media bias because this is a
woman who's about to shatter the glass
ceiling yes so she should be praised by
the left-wing media but instead she's
trying to be railroaded because she was
nominated by a Republican and the media
for years has been saying that women
should be celebrated because they're
playing in the big boys leagues and
they're tough and we need tough women
that can really you know take the fight
to people now we actually have a woman
like that who made terrorists whine and
whimper and they're trying to attack her
you know what scares me is I think that
Democratic husbands are gonna tell their
wives not to support her and they won't
because they're so subservient all right
why I'm gonna give you the argument that
I always hear that our tactics
interrogation tactics fuel the people
who hate us it's like we just make it
worse because we're lowering ourselves
to that level is that how you feel yeah
I don't think it's very American to
torture people and neither does John
McCain who was tortured not to work so
what'd you get it and it is torture
what's a [ __ ]
that's not tortured water well I don't
know you can maybe in your pet you know
your free time you want to go reported
correspondents you don't think that is
rational or say nobody in their right
mind so I mean maybe it's a difference
what's your alternative we're right
which implant would there are lots of
all times that I would talk to the
intelligence community they will tell
you they get more out of people when
they don't torture them some but here's
the thing it did I think the key here is
will she renounce the use of torture in
confirmation hearings I think that's
what Dianne Feinstein had to say today
which is look she's got a great
reputation in the intelligence community
they call her a pro's Pro but the law
has changed torture is illegal but in
this administration with President Trump
who by the way he's always putting down
the CIA but says he thinks torture is
effective what about Mike Pompeo who was
the former CIA director he too has said
yeah I think
torture might work so the question
becomes wait a second are we going
backwards here having had a moment of
conscience about this where we were
torturing people even after the fact it
wasn't any like you know 24 scenario
where all we got to get some information
so we're just doing have fun has been
now taken care of we have no can say the
president has the right to say I need
this information take extraordinary or
enhanced interrogation tactics but these
people that she was torturing those
people was on you waterboard me without
the water
sloppy use of the word torture I'll tell
you right now it's it's waterboarding if
it's putting you in a boat yeah some of
these guys are real losers and real
wimps okay they're crybabies you put a
caterpillar on their shoulder and they
cry for their moms and no more jihad and
they spill it so that to me is not
torture it really is it well I'm just
hold your wine or there's some sleep
deprivation there's been changes in law
she will follow the law as it currently
stands on the boat right that's what
that's why she will she renounced the
use of torture know what that leads me
the question Dana would you break the
law if you say could save lives and ruin
your career or would you follow the law
and watch people die that's an
interesting question that leads me to
her saying extreme she didn't break it
just call a fighter soft because of you
I was doing a 24 the other thing that I
mean obviously there's not any it's not
an easy top the things that these agents
are asked to do yes are not easy you
think they want to do this they like
they signed up to serve their country
and order to protect us but the notion
that somehow Gitmo or these black sites
somehow fueled more anger against
Western civilization is preposterous and
that is a great point because after
these enhanced interrogations were no
longer used the rise of Isis
yes yeah brung up right after it so what
does they have to do with each other
while the other thing is well that have
to do with it I think it's constant you
said when we were interrogating people
in a rough way that that was making them
hate us even more no matter what it's an
ideology that we're fighting anyway I
think that she'll end up with 75 votes
in favor good all right